it's amazing how much of our modern
political morality is influenced by the
philosopher John Stuart Mill the mill
wasn't the first person to champion
individual freedom of choice but the
case he makes in on Liberty his most
famous work is like a diamond of thought
put most succinctly he says that over
himself over his own body and mind the
individual is sovereign and if you want
to understand the complex issue of who
has the right to die you have to start
here because it's this principle of
personal autonomy except in cases where
opposes harm to others that forms its
moral and legal basis in American courts
at least the possession of that autonomy
has become synonymous with the word
dignity and words terms in this debate
have a lot of importance they frame the
way we think of the question of doctor
assisted suicide in the beginning it was
called euthanasia in 1938 dr. Charles
Francis Potter a Unitarian priest and
humanists founded the euthanasia Society
of America the first group to seriously
proposed legislation that would legalize
Mercy death at least that's what the New
York Times called the euthanasia Society
didn't like the terms death and killing
they preferred merciful release of
course for much of the public the term
euthanasia was already a bit too close
to eugenics something that the Nazis
were going to make disgustingly clear in
the next few years and the society
wasn't doing much distinguishing itself
in the words of its president euthanasia
was for born defectives who were doomed
to remain defective if that terrifies
you it should so for those who saw a
genuine moral imperative to help
terminal sufferers and their life on
their terms it was an uphill battle and
that battle too was waged in words in
1976 the euthanasia Society of America
changed their name to the Society for
the right to die in 1992 they changed it
again to choice and died in 1993 another
group formed called compassion in dying
and in 2002 the former hemlock society
changed its
to end of life choices finally merging
with compassion and dying in 2003 to
form compassion and choices you can see
during a process of decades a careful
reframing of the debate as one about
choice and personal autonomy I Cosmo
Kramer having just seen the movie the
other side of darkness and not wanting
to be in a coma like that lady in the
movie hereby want Jerry Seinfeld to
remove my life support feeding machine
lung blower etc etc etc the first
victories came in the form of advanced
care directives or living wills and the
court decisions were loaded with the
language of autonomy and dignity to
justify pulling the plug in the case of
brain death and then when the first
physician-assisted death laws were
passed dignity was front and center
again indeed such laws are often called
death with dignity laws today five
states effectively allow physician
assisted death and in each the
medication can only be prescribed when
certain requirements are met in Oregon
for example you have to among other
things be terminally ill with a fatal
diagnosis of less than six months the
day that I learned that I was terminally
ill that there was nothing that medicine
could do to ameliorate even my symptoms
I decided that I wanted to live as long
as I could as best I was able and I
wanted to die with the dignity with
which I had lived
it's an extraordinary issue physician
assisted death it's legal victories have
been carved carefully from a complex and
dangerous moral backdrop in a country
where depression rates are as high as
this one it's not without risk to
sanction any form of suicide Death with
Dignity laws limit themselves to
terminally ill patients exclusively
because it's the only instance in which
we can recognize a rational desire to
end one's own life in all other cases
suicide is a permanent solution to a
temporary problem of course opponents of
physician-assisted death don't see a
moral right in any instance of suicide a
lot of those opponents fall on the
conservative or religious side of this
but there's also a split among
progressives particularly on the part of
disability rights activists when those
seeking aid and dying lists the reasons
for their choice reasons such as the
inability to live without help being a
burden on their loved ones things often
refer to as indignities activists point
out that those with disability live with
such conditions for their entire life
they say that physician assisted death
laws can paint these kinds of lives as
undignified and that creates a larger
culture that devalues the disabled this
is what happens when an abstract concept
like dignity a concept that has no fixed
meaning in bioethics is invested with so
much weight eighty-one percent of people
who seek lethal medication do so because
they worry about a quote loss of dignity
and yet whether dignity is a property
that can be lost is still a matter of
philosophical debate I should say now
that physician assisted death is
something that I support but not without
a little hesitation a hesitation that's
demanded I think by the blurred
boundaries of a moral question like this
one the objections posed by
conservatives disability rights
activists and others must be taken into
account
they don't negate its need but they do
warn us that discussion across the table
is needed if we're going to draft laws
as subtle as the issue is mine is the
morality of John Stuart Mill in 2015 at
only the latest moment in our effort to
understand the intricacies of individual
liberty and at the heart of Liberty is
the right to define one's own concept of
existence meaning of the universe and of
the mystery of human life
and death of my silence hey everybody
thanks for watching
it was so enlightening researching and
learning about this issue it was just so
many sides to it that I wasn't aware of
before if we're diving into this so
thank you for watching and thank you to
eli samuel for turning me on to this and
inspiring me to do this if you want to
see more videos where i explore topics
like this you can pledge to my patreon
page by clicking right here everything
helps it is what makes this channel
possible I said it over and over again
but it really is true and you guys have
been amazing and the quality of the
content I hope you see has gotten better
as I've been able to do this full-time
so thank you so much for that and I will
see you guys next Wednesday